one of the beauties of film is that it
knows no boundaries from three
continents and five different countries
the nominees for the best foreign
language film have reached audiences
around the world with heroic works of
art that speak a universal language as
diverse as they are dynamic these films
transcend borders and connect us with
our collective conscience and common
creative spirit here are the nominees
for Best Foreign Language Film from
Belgium the broken circle breakdown
directed by felix von cunningham from
italy the great beauty directed by Paolo
Sorrentino from Denmark the hunt
directed by Thomas Vinterberg from
Cambodia the missing picture directed by
Ritchie pond from Palestine Omar
directed by Hani abu-assad an Oscar goes
to the great beauty it's all a part of
something
okay thank you to the Academy thank you
to Tony and Nicole and all the actors
producers and the crew thank you to my
sources of inspiration Federico Fellini
Tolkien aids Marty Scorsese and the dig
armando maradona and I think you to Rome
and to Napoli and my personal a great
beauty Daniela and Carlo and thank you
to my brother Marco my sister Daniella
and the disease for my parents society
No thank you very much